get it edit and done turn it on do you
really need anything else for the intro
this video really Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles out of the shadows so Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles out of the shadows
is the sequel to the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles that came out a couple
years ago and in this movie shredders
back he's skimming a plan he makes bebop
and Rocksteady the turtles once again
have to stop him with her new friend
Casey Jones we all saw the trailers you
know what this movies gonna be about ok
so I have some prizes to sing about this
movie because they fix a lot of the
gripes I had in the first movie
first of all shredders an actual human
being he's not a big transformer
monstrosity they use Will Arnett in this
movie a way they could use well Internet
in this movie I mean I you probably has
a contract for three movies so in that
they could have omitted him entirely but
he's probably contractually obligated to
be in this movie that said they use him
in a way that makes me not want to
actually shoot myself in the face
blender is not a dick in this movie like
he was in the first movie he's actually
a mentor and a father and the four
turtles actually exhibit the
personalities and I know the turtles to
be and this movie has fanservice for
days now I'm not saying fanservice makes
a great movie I'm saying it's an
entertaining movie because the movie
committed it's kinda like I don't know
if you guys watch Gotham on Fox like I
watched a few episodes of season one I
was like I can't get into this because
this show does not know what it wants to
be half of it wants to be a Batman show
but half of it wants to be a cop show
involving Jim Gordon so is that a cop
shows at a Batman show it's straddling
the line in the middle doesn't know what
it wants to be it needs to commit to a
side season to committed to his sights
like they were like all right we take
place in Gotham City so let's see some
villain origins let's see some Batman
right side okay left side okay in
the middle just like great so I actually
enjoyed Gotham season 2 this Ninja
Turtles movie is like that it's like
they were like alright we're made for
kids that being said those kids are
going to have parents those parents
watch the Ninja Turtles TV show the
cartoon in the late 80s Early 90s so
let's give them fanservice let's
entertain people and if you're able to
turn your brain off and just watch the
movie for what it is it's actually
pretty damn entertaining that's not
perfect toy let's talk about Casey Jones
Casey Jones is in this movie kind of
they have a guy who's called Casey Jones
who doesn't exhibit anything I know
Casey Jones to be now granted Stephen
Amell who plays him I think it's great
that said he's not Casey Jones at all
and he's not really relevant he serves
as fresh new eyes to be in on the whole
turtle sing for this movie his
integration into the crew just isn't
done well at all generally speaking
Casey Jones is an outsider Raphael is an
outsider Casey Jones and Raphael
gravitate towards each other and they
form a friendship he doesn't really form
a friendship with anybody he hits on
April O'Neil a couple times yeah they're
attractive people they're gonna be
attracted to each other but this guy
just served to keep bebop and rocksteady
busy and a couple action sequences
speaking of action sequences let's talk
about the action sequences action is
pretty entertaining itself that that
plane scene other than the fact that
Raphael smacks the windshield of this
airplane that we see in the trailer it
would completely kill him but there is
an action sequence that starts out in
this plane and ends up down a river and
that whole thing I was just thoroughly
entertained the physics make no sense
whatsoever don't try to make sense of it
at all I'm just saying if you can just
watch it and enjoy it it's pretty
entertaining people should have died
though no one died people should have
but once again the last act of this
movie like the last movie just becomes a
big mess granted there's fanservice in
that mess and among the mess I was like
oh that's really cool that said yeah
this is messing what really pissed
me off is in this movie they actually
made shredder a person they make him a
character who's actually doing stuff so
you're like all right there's gonna be a
rematch in the last movie the turtles
fought a big robot on a high-rise and
that shredders gonna have a rematch he's
gonna be a human being he's gonna fight
the Turtles but in out of the shadows
shredder takes a back seat not even in
on the fight the turtles have to fight
Krang so once again the turtles have to
fight a big robot on a high-rise like
the last movie it's the same thing you
saw last time and it's the same thing
going through your mind as last time
you're like this isn't why are we doing
this would have been so much cooler to
have shredder take on the turtles in a
rematch granted yes shredder could
probably not take a lot of hits from the
turtle maybe that's the cool part maybe
he's just so good he just kicks their
eyes like what I'm so much better than
you in every turtles arc ever when it
comes to shredder and Krang shredder is
always cooler Krang should take a
backseat to shredder not the other way
around guys in the end Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles out of the shadows is
better than the first movie for me for
sure and that stems because the movie's
new were to hit me bad service doesn't
make a great movie
this movie is not a great movie but the
movie is entertaining I walked out going
I was surprisingly entertained in this
Ninja Turtles movie because the movie
doesn't try to be something it's not
guys you know who you are and I'm
to rely on your power yes you watching
this you have power you have the power
to know what you like in movies and
entertainment so when I say I was
entertained and I say Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles out of the shadows was a
good time no alcohol required for me
I'll take that to the bank
I mean if you saw the trailers and
you're like yeah that sucks and you hear
my review and my assessment you're like
yeah it still sounds like it sucks don't
watch it it'll probably suck for you
greatest end credits song ever though
ever I'm just sayin alright guys so
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles out of the
shadows have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
turtle power
what